black panther wakanda forever is in
theaters Michelle Turner sat down with
the cast who revealed their initial
struggle to push forward without their
King Chadwick Boseman
when Chadwick died I mean I was lost for
for a few months there and I had no idea
how we'd come back to wakanda
I couldn't even
what we were doing next with it with the
story after that devastating loss of our
brother my king stop the reason why I
have the role of Sherry is because of
Chadwick because I'm saying yo this is
my sister stop auditioning people yeah
so the Y just came back I'm doing it for
him in spite of their grief there was
one bright spot for this cast welcoming
Marvel's newest Latino actors Mabel
Cadena Alex levenali and tanoch Huerta
they're members of a mine inspired
underworld at odds with the wakandans in
Black Panther wakanda forever in
theaters today when you step into this
family Dynamic on this set how was that
it's like oh my God I feel representing
the Mexican culture I love and the Latin
American culture and it's like wow of
course you have the loss of Chadwick on
top of walking into to this franchise we
hear so many stories of the things that
he would say from the returning cast of
returning crew members we kind of felt
like we knew him a bit
they are so warm so it felt like uh you
are the the kind of causing yeah living
in another country and then you go to it
show them
are you gonna sit down and watch it I
don't know I'm I'm gonna do it when I'm
ready you know it took a lot to make
this film and I just want to watch it
when my mind and spirit is prepared
foreign